si je vous dis le 6 janvier 1949 c'était
quel jour c'était un jeudi bravo c'est
le jour de ma naissance
gravité du samedi 20h ce soir Daniel
tamad bonsoir
Daniel vous êtes autiste asperger vous
avez été élu parmi les 100 génies
vivants vous êtes l'auteur de plusieurs
best-sellers et vous publiez le 17
janvier l'éternité dans une heure aux
éditions Les Arènes on en reparle dans
un instant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir donc vous êtes à notiste
asperger ce que l'on appelle communément
un autiste savant et vous possédez des
dons exceptionnels en calcul et dans
l'apprentissage des langues mais le plus
exceptionnel si vous êtes un des seuls à
pouvoir faire des allers-retours entre
notre monde et le monde de l'autisme
c'est pour ça que les scientifiques vous
surnomme la Pierre de Rosette de
l'autisme d'après le nom de cette pierre
qui a permis de décrypter les
hiéroglyphes alors j'ai déjà publié deux
livres vendu un million d'exemplaires et
vous revenez aujourd'hui avec l'éternité
dans une heure la poésie des nombres
publiée aux éditions Les Arènes alors
Daniel vous êtes né le 31 janvier 1979 à
Londres père ouvrier mer secrétaire
famille de neuf enfants
alors jusqu'à l'âge de deux ans vous
êtes un enfant difficile très bruyant et
puis soudain vous devenez silencieux
vous commencez à développer les premiers
symptômes de l'autisme mais l'âge de 4
ans vous êtes secoué par des crises
d'épilepsie de plus en plus graves vous
manquez d'ailleurs dans d'en mourir
heureusement mon père il a eu la bon
réflexe parce que son père avait crise
d'appeler psy également donc elle a
reconnu tout de suite
le problème et il m'a amené tout de
suite à l'hôpital et
alors l'épilepsie évidemment c'est un
symptôme courant chez les autistes
méfiez-vous
l'épilepsie a eu un impact déterminant
sur la construction de votre cerveau
c'est à dire que certaines connexions
neuronales étaient endommagées et le
cerveau des incontournés et on a créé
une nouvelle voilà alors chez vous avec
neuf enfants évidemment il y a beaucoup
de bruit ce qui est une souffrance pour
vous vous réfugiez dans votre monde
peuplé de chiffres vous comptez vous
calculez si votre univers puis un jour
je découvre parce qu'à l'époque il y
avait pas de promo dans un parti de
l'autre très très modeste il y a pas de
cinéma du musée pas de théâtre il y
avait un bibliothèque je regarde les
livres partout partout avec les noms et
chaque livre avec son nom différent et
je me suis dit si je regarde suisusement
longtemps je vais trouver le livre avec
mon nom dessus et je vais découvrir
l'histoire de ma vie je vais revoir
qu'est-ce qui va se passer mon avenir et
bien sûr j'ai jamais trouvé ce livre et
plus tard que j'ai compris fallait
d'abord écrire ce livre que j'ai fait
exactement c'est une idée à la Borghèse
ça d'arriver dans une bibliothèque et
chercher le livre qui raconte votre vie
extraordinaire alors les livres qui vous
intéresse c'est les dictionnaires les
encyclopédie et puis effectivement les
mots prennent un peu comme les chiffres
une couleur une forme une texture une
émotion et ces mots deviennent vos seuls
compagnons oui en fait c'est comme si
les mots prenaient le relais un peu des
des nombres mais je suis dans un univers
donc de ces combinaisons des métaphores
la poésie
je découvre la fiction parce que c'est
pas évident pour quelqu'un qui a ce
spectre autiste de comprendre la fiction
et tout ça dans le monde normal vous
êtes un peu un alien on peut le dire et
vous êtes très très sensible par exemple
chez vous quand vous êtes petit quand
votre mère
montre l'escalier vous attendez son son
pas
pour vous c'est une souffrance une
violence quoi oui parce que les bruits
qu'on sait aléatoire je savais pas
qu'est-ce que c'est et j'arrivais pas à
mettre une émotion quelque chose dessus
alors à l'époque donc dans les années 80
le syndrome asperger n'est pas
diagnostiqué donc on vous met à l'école
comme tout le monde c'est une expérience
extrêmement douloureuse pour vous parce
que vous êtes timide enfermé solitaire
silencieux très difficile parce que je
ne suis pas comme les autres quand on
est petit quand on est enfant on veut
être comme les autres alors là je de 10
ans vous découvrez chez des voisins à
vous d'origine finlandaise le finnois et
là c'est votre début de l'exploration
des langues étrangères
aujourd'hui vous en maîtrisez une
dizaine alors l'anglais le finnois le
lituanien l'espagnol le français
l'allemand l'islandais le roumain le
Gallois et l'espéranto
[Musique]
vous avez créé votre propre langue le
menti oui parce que quand on aime les
mots on veut jouer avec et c'est une
langue où il y a beaucoup de voyelles
parce que vous dites que c'est plus joli
que les consonnes
est-ce que nous dire bonjour je vais
bien on menti par exemple
et va
coûter vous êtes le seul à Paris cette
langue ah oui
alors à l'adolescence vous découvrez la
fiction les romans le théâtre et surtout
Shakespeare Shakespeare est une
révélation pour vous parce que grâce à
Shakespeare vous découvrez le langage
social c'est à dire l'empathie la
dispute l'amour la haine en fait
j'expire vous socialise d'une certaine
exactement parce que pour la première
fois je comprends le pouvoir de la
littérature en fait et puis Shakespeare
il parlait énormément des mathématiques
parler surtout par exemple de chiffres 0
parce qu'à l'époque de Shakespeare ça
n'existait pas mais vous dites c'est la
première génération qui a été élevée
avec le chiffre 0 ça n'existait pas
avant lui alors toujours pendant
adolescence amusez beaucoup avec les
chiffres faites des multiplications très
complexes vous dites d'ailleurs je ne
calcule pas je vois le résultat voilà en
fait je me suis absolument pas à
noterateur auquel il a triste j'ai du
mal avec des choses comme la job et tout
ça puisque c'est les choses qui sont pas
tangibles et pour moi c'est
il faut toujours que ça soit quelque
chose d'humain de concret alors vous
faites aussi du calcul calendaire alors
je vais pas vous considérer comme un
singe savant et vous faire faire plein
de trucs mais si je vous dis le 6
janvier 1949 c'était quel jour c'était
un jeudi bravo c'est ma naissance voilà
alors vous découvrez à ce moment-là le
nombre pi alors le nombre pi bon ben on
a tous appris ça c'est trois cannes pour
nous c'est ça tu as 3 14 3 14 116 vous
vous décidez d'apprendre le plus grand
nombre de décimales possible et le 3
mars 2004 vous en réciterez des
décimales du nombre pi
22514 alors il a mis des papiers sur les
murs c'est ça et vous avez photographié
d'une certaine façon c'est à dire oui en
fait le nombre pi pour moi c'est quand
même poème numérique pour moi le nombre
ça voulait dire quelque chose chaque
chiffre avait un sens donc il fallait
simplement que j'entre dedans et je suis
allé dans un musée en Angleterre pour
réciter ce nombre devant un public
et c'était incroyable parce que les gens
ils ont absolument pas dans les
mathématiques à tous les sons des
ouvriers des des gens de partout et en
même temps ils étaient tellement touché
pendant la récitation parfois même les
gens qui pleuraient et je me suis dit
j'ai compris en fait pour première fois
que j'avais ce don de passe un bon de
compter mais de raconter pour vous c'est
un peu comme la Joconde ou une symphonie
de Mozart quoi ça vient ça vient une
oeuvre d'art quoi exactement donc vous
récitez ces 22514 décimales sans faire
une seule erreur un véritable marathon a
vous arrêtez de temps en temps mais à
des moments prédéfinis c'est-à-dire tous
les 1000 chiffres vous arrêtez pour
manger un carré de chocolat ou un fruit
mais c'est tout quand vous allez aux
toilettes on vous accompagne pour être
sûr que vous parlez à personne donc
c'est vraiment fait pratiquement sous
contrôle d'huissier quoi oui exactement
c'était très puisque c'est un record
donc il fallait absolument que que ça
soit vérifié le défi suivant
c'est d'apprendre l'islandais en une
semaine c'est incroyable et vous l'avez
fait je l'ai fait vous avez répondu une
semaine après une interview qui vous
était faite en islandais comme comment
on est en train de faire un enfant
français j'ai été en Islande en Islande
et en Islande et
une expérience encore une fois c'est les
couleurs et tout ça à chaque fois il y
avait un sens j'ai essayé d'associer les
couleurs avec les sens des mots et tout
ça de créer comme une toile d'araignée
avec des connexions des et c'était très
ludique c'était très et puisse à chaque
fois
j'ai eu tellement du mal en fond
à comprendre et à communiquer que là
maintenant je suis à fond dans la
communication
c'est un génie il nous aura été donné de
voir un génie au moins une fois dans
notre vie moi j'y croirais quand il
parlera le peuple en 7 jours
il peut le faire
je pense à la musique évidemment je
pense à des gens que tu citais tout à
l'heure comme comme Mozart est-ce que tu
enfin tu aimes la musique est-ce que tu
as imaginé mettre ça en fait ton don
enfin ton nom en pratique c'est ça je
suis en train d'écrire une chanson une
chanson juste le texte pour une chanson
parce qu'il y a moyen d'écrire
alors il faut que vous me preniez alors
[Applaudissements]
alors Mozart était asperger on pense
aujourd'hui non
il y a beaucoup de gens
on dit peut-être des certains poètes
aiment les Dickinson et très connu aux
États-Unis Louise Caron un grand
écrivain
mathématicien également
asperger aussi on savait pas parce que
le mot n'existait pas à l'époque donc
c'est très récent c'est très récent et
mais pour moi c'est très positif parce
que avant j'avais toujours le sentiment
j'avais tort j'étais paresseux pourquoi
j'étais pas comme les autres pourquoi
les gens me comprenaient pas et là
maintenant je vois que voilà la
différence c'est pas un handicap merci
beaucoup Daniel c'est passionnant c'est
génial merci et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu